this is the big challenge our economy is
is
what do we drop like 30 or like 30
something percent this year potentially
yeah
people are we're facing mass evictions
unemployment
yep the reason i pointed out the
printing of money is that that is
absolutely not a solution in any
capacity
it's a it's a desperate last resort
where they're just like
money printer gober desperately trying
to keep the machine churning in some
capacity
but if people ultimately stop doing
things that give them the money value
then ultimately we just we're headed
towards some kind of really serious
economic collapse especially
with so if something i'm not going to
disagree with you here and we talked a
little bit about the software
the problem is is that right now we have
the worst of both worlds
and that we are doing half-assed
lockdowns that are locking down just
enough to absolutely destroy
small businesses and and and average
workers but we're not locking down
enough to prevent the spread of the
disease so what we're getting is the
disease is spreading almost uninhibited
or it almost feels like it's uninhibited
i'm sure it has been to some extent and
then we're seeing all these businesses
close down and
because we're doing it in such a in such
a laxative manner
like nothing is actually moving in a
positive direction we haven't eliminated
the virus on any part of the us we're
still in like that map this isn't like
purple spreading in almost every i think
in every single state
and then people are suffering severe
economic arm as well right now whatever
we're doing i
like if you were to ask me like well
should we just not lock down anything
whatever if it was between
just doing no lockdowns and doing what
we're doing now i might even say like
okay yeah like like
whatever i think that's i think that's
it actually sure the the guy at the
restaurant that i mentioned
in michigan he straight up said if the
government gave me enough money to to
keep everything moving
i'd happily walk away for two months
yeah for sure i think it really just
comes down to
is if we're gonna shut down businesses
we have to support them through the
shutdown you can't just
expect people to stay home and have you
know you know we don't expect american
airlines or walmart or any other massive
corporation have six months of savings
um and these people are doing revenue in
the 9 10 11 digits like
why do you expect you know frank that
owns a bar down the street to you know
like small business owners aren't making
tens of millions of dollars a year off
of their business you know these people
aren't going to have the savings to
get through six months of not operating
their business it's a tough problem
um i think you have a lot of people on
the right saying protect the vulnerable
social distance wear masks but reopen
things
and then many on the left i suppose you
know in your instance
lock everything down hard but cover the
cost to make sure people make it through
this
well the thing that sucks is it feels
like and this has been i'm gonna i
so look forward i i want to feel like
this argument is never gonna come back
again but i know it will underbide him
republicans always cry about deficit
spending but for some reason when their
deficit spending for their pet projects
it seems like it's okay
i don't understand why we got trillions
of dollars of tax cuts from trump
that he celebrated about it you know
growing the economy which
congratulations every time you have the
deficit don't tax yeah
and massive debt he campaigned biggest
budget deficits under trump
of all time some of the biggest budget
uh deficits of all time
and i think the thing that leaves people
frustrated is it's like i don't
understand why you can't help
us why can't you give us money if you
are spending so much
on the war machine which was supposed to
go away or on you know large businesses
tax cuts and everything like it's
serious that's the frustrating part
trump campaigned against the deficit and
the debt and and here we are and there
was there was an interview with ted cruz
where he was like you know
well trump didn't campaign against that
they're like he did he did explicitly
yeah
i think that's an indication of like you
know political parties
will say one thing but as soon as they
get power you know what i mean like
everybody wants free speech when they're
in the minority position and then once
they're in the dominant position they're
like no no we gotta we gotta clamp
things down
maybe you want i mean yeah i mean a man
carrying over 400 400 million dollars of
personally guaranteed debt probably
isn't going to be the best person to
responsibly manage a country's budget
either but
yeah but see that's that's a framing
thing you're right there right yes so
it's a framing i'm framing that a man
that has a massive amount of personal
debt that he's personally guaranteed
that's right
orders assets probably enough to cover
it but probably not another 3.2 billion
but i i think there was a it was either
wall street journal uh one that went
over that yeah
but anytime you're having to start to
sell off things that you owned to cover
that you're bringing
it's probably not a good feeling you can
do it yeah yeah uh forbes i think put
trump at 3.2 billion with
with liabilities of like 400 million
something like that yeah so yeah
you know i don't want to i don't want to
go off on a news thing so yeah
it doesn't i i it's frustrating to
center back it's frustrating
to me and a lot of other people um on
the left and i imagine on the right as
well that constantly hear about how we
can't just spend all this money on
you but right could do massive tax cuts
and we could spend a lot of money on
overseas wars and that just seems very
wrong
yep yeah man the war me you get me going
on the war thing absolutely
spending money doing nation building in
foreign countries when we could be
fixing the pipes in flint and helping
people in this country
that's the interesting thing i think you
know ultimately what it comes down to
with the lockdown debate is
i think if we work out all of those
issues what's left is
will the two-month mass printing of
money have a serious detrimental effect
on the economy the savings
and the uh you know retirements of
american people
will it be a bad thing for them you know
or
if we that's basically it right so
conservatives would say we can't just
print money we can't just do that we
can't just lock everything down and
freeze it
especially at this point considering
it's been a year now when businesses
have been destroyed
and i guess the leftist position is you
can and you have to
um yeah i guess it monetary policies are
very complicated
um i know that there's always the uh
inflation boogeyman that is looming
behind every politically expedient
argument but it seems like we haven't
seen that massive uninflation yet
uh we've been running historically low
uh federal funds rates for long times
now it just isn't there i know that
there's at least five libertarians right
now in chat screaming that we need to go
back to the gold standard and we're
printing money and it's out of bed
do you see that that trump i think was
trumpy tried appointing a woman to the
federal reserve who wants to be on the
go wants to put us back on the gold
standard that's
very funny um i thought it was hilarious
yeah but absolutely delusional
um but yeah no i mean um we need to get
ron paul in here you can have an
argument about
what's delusional about the oh oh wait
are you asking me or would ron paul ask
me that no no no like ron paul would
clearly be like you're right you're
crazy
of course yeah man i was a huge run paul
supporter when i was back in college
really yeah
what the heck so so let's let's let's do
this let's we'll uh
look man i think i think we agree that
we we have to go one way or the other
we're sitting on the fence
we either need to jump into the we're
gonna lock down for two months
everybody's getting some kind of handout
or we need to go into like okay we're
gonna severely lax all the lockdown
stuff and we're just gonna see who dies
but like we have to keep people's lives
running because there is damage
uh there is collateral damage to a
lockdown that people are suicidal
accept more even more so this is not
having your business not be able to run
anything mental health issues
like yeah actually yeah there's a really
well known twitch streamer that killed
himself
most likely because of the lockdowns um
a friend of mine that traveled a ton and
that was like his way of getting i know
there are a lot of people like that
maybe that not necessarily kill
themselves but like severely like
negatively impacted in terms of mental
health related to that so yeah wow man
i've heard a lot of stories there was a
there's this dude that i know
his son committed suicide he was
tweeting about it and said having
having a young kid who's locked up and
with
even with with resources guys wealthy
dude that's just it destroys their mind
you know not to mention that like i
can't imagine my so i'm very like i have
a nine-year-old son
um because of how they because he lives
in a wealthy school district because i'm
wealthy
um they have long distance learning with
like ipads and stuff
and even for them even for that
technologically very literate school
district
i get the emails every day i don't know
if other parents have this issue it's
like hey guys if you got logged out of
the ipads you know like this is how you
get back in or like it just seems to be
like such a nightmare for everybody
i can't imagine the poorest schools that
can afford that type of technology that
i don't i don't know what those people
are
out of school for like a year some
people didn't get to have their senior
prom some people didn't get to do their
graduation
like i would have cheered for all that
i'm you know i when i was when i was
younger whatever as well very naughty
establishment
well i just want to say we play video
games but most people probably wanted to
see their friends and socialize and do
stuff
yup well so that's a good argument why
there shouldn't be electrons for the
sake of mental health and everyone and
actually or a good argument for why we
should have had very strict lockdowns
for two months and then maybe
started to do like much more controlled
re-openings like than in australia new
zealand or south korea
so then the problem isn't so much a
conspiracy as it is two factions
fighting and getting a half-assed
response instead of one solid response
to either the problem is that literally
every single thing in the united states
is so unbelievably politicized that you
can't do
anything without somebody looking at you
like you have a political agenda behind
it
and part of the reason is because of
stuff like talking about the great reset
like
that on its face if you were to say like
hey if you are doing like a massive
restructuring do you think you should
take that opportunity to optimize like
part of your workflow
every reasonable person like yeah
probably yeah but like when it's phrased
and that like
do you think that people are pushing for
extra coronavirus lockdowns just so they
can shove aoc into every person's home
forcing you to get on your knees and
worship the green new deals like
well okay like i i feel like the framing
of that is a little bit disingenuous and
it further serves like that hardcore
hyper partisan politicization
of american politics the world economic
forum put out a video that said in 2030
you will own nothing and you will be
happy
so when they say the world economic
forum do you mean like one person who
works in one sub section that does
youtube videos
published it it was published on all
social platforms they wrote they were a
big long article about it
and then they later clarified when there
was a backlash that it wasn't intended
to say this is what we want to happen
but what we think may happen
so the issue is if you if you launch a
campaign around this
you include within it like critical
theory
intersectionality and stuff and then you
say you will own nothing and you will be
happy
and then that people like trudeau who
say we're gonna have a reset people like
john kerry
are advocating for locking everything
down which is destroying ownership sure
it's like people yeah i'll put this way
yeah not that it's a grand conspiracy
where they all got together and said we
want to destroy ownership
but that they think it's a good thing
they like it they've advocated for it
and now the policies they're bringing
about are bringing about what they want
sure so you can argue yeah i understand
the problem is that like i can't
argue against a story i can only argue
against particular policies
um so like if we are concocting this
grand narrative behind the schemes that
we're trying to get rid of ownership of
everything and blah blah blah
and like this like well i mean like we
have like a bunch of discreet facts and
we could connect them in that way if we
want to but i don't know if it's the
most perfect way to do it
and even on its face i could even defend
that statement on its face that actually
a lot of people are in support of that
that you will own nothing to be happy
um so as a gamer something that's been
very interesting to me is most people
today
use things like steam as a platform you
don't own any of that i don't know if
you're familiar with steven course
yeah absolutely you don't own any of
those right if valve goes bankrupt
you've lost everything
sure but but the convenience that it
provides is you know on another level
and that's why people like it or you
don't own any of your music you listen
to it on spotify you listen to it on
itunes we don't have the
um the vinyls we don't have the cds we
don't have any of that anymore so like
i'm not now i'm not defending the idea
that we should own nothing okay i'm an
ardent capitalist i like owning things
um i for i have all of my music is
backed up on flak files on my hard
drives that i keep it up because i like
that
however i don't think that these ideas
are necessarily as crazy as we make them
out to be
because we give the least charitable
reading of it and then run with the
biggest conspiracy behind it instead of
like
what's like a more nuanced like approach
in the middle for like what do they
probably mean
what are the goods and what are the pros
and cons and like how can we you know
work with this i guess
i i think i think conspiracy implies
that it's a secret of some sort
i will just call it yeah that's enough
for me to say sure when i say conspiracy
language sure yeah i understand when i
say conspiracy i don't mean like a crazy
you know lunatic when i say conspiracy i
mean like a planned thing that multiple
people are working on to bring about
some kind of change it's like a
conspiracy
um but i just have a very negative
connotation so i understand yeah
there's a group of people they have
international interests they think we
should use the
coveted lockdown to reset global
capitalism
and then there's people who don't trust
the policies they're putting out when
the world health organization themselves
i have the quote sure let's see if i can
uh
full lockdowns should be a very very
last resort and can be avoided world
health organizations europe chief
says so this was in october that when
when when you see the story and it was
it was basically carried over i'm using
cnbc
people are wondering why then they're
pushing for all these lockdowns i don't
know
i don't think we've even pushed for full
lockdowns anywhere in the u.s have we
uh no we haven't so we haven't even done
a full look what do you mean by full
lockdown
well what do they mean by full lockdown
i imagine that the whole probably
doesn't mean when they say like full
lockdown
i doubt they mean like outdoor seating
at all hours of the day
at most restaurants yeah when they say
full lockdown they're probably saying
like closed
because i've been in california for a
couple years now i don't think we've
full locked down anything you can go to
any questions a couple years but over
the past years like you can still go out
to restaurants you're just outdoor
seating or you're sitting in every other
place
california says don't leave your home
past 10 o'clock i think just recently
they did that i think newsom said on
monday i think they just said like no
more gatherings of 10 more people yeah
but this is the i think this is the
first time california's went this far
but even at that i'm pretty sure
restaurants are still open like i
literally ordered din tai fung like the
day before we
we left like we went to the restaurant
and picked it up there were still people
eating out there and everything so
it's interesting too yeah because well
it's the constitution there's only so
much they can do to enforce this stuff
you look at europe and they had they had
this uh video go viral of a woman who
brought her mom to
uh a mental health facility and they
detained her taste her
she's screaming and then naturally
people are like this is messed up
i mean actually you made it sound like
you you disagreed with australia and new
zealand's approach to things because
australia's been super draconian
i don't necessarily disagree um i just i
wish that we had a more
three-dimensional view of what it means
to have the right to do something
because the way that when i grew up the
way that i was taught is that when you
get more rights being an adult is
awesome but there
is more responsibility that comes along
with that there's no you're never given
a right to do something
that doesn't carry a greater burden of
responsibility behind it like that's
always the case
um and a lot of the times when i talk
it's so weird when republicans talk
about rights
usually they're talking about
restricting rights i notice that any
time a republican talks about states
rights what they're actually talking
about is taking rights away from you
they want to like curb like abortion or
they want to restrict access to like
funding like planned parenthood like
they usually or they want to make it
harder to vote for whatever reason voter
id or if you don't agree with that make
it harder whatever like it feels like
when people talk about like states
rights
um what they they uh or make it illegal
for like gay people to get right they're
talking about like taking rights away
from people which is
old examples well now they are because
the supreme court said
but i mean there was that famous um who
was the woman that uh mike huckabee
supported
who was saying like i'm not gonna marry
you know these gay people even if they
wouldn't work
yeah yeah so these are thankfully some
of these are older examples sure
um but even with even regarding things
like um uh like uh what do you call the
city sanctuary cities right people like
states shouldn't have the right to do
that we need to take this back or we
need to like
it it feels a lot a lot of the times
like when people talk about states
rights
it feels like they're actually talking
about taking right to wave people which
is only a couple of
examples where just security well like
i mean what is security but the
restriction of a right in exchange for
what's the quote like
somebody that demands uh security in
exchange for their freedom will get and
deserve neither
well we'll get night we'll lose we'll
we'll get neither and lose yeah sure
well so but the argument it really is
yeah it comes down to uh
freedom versus security and at a certain
point you do need security
it's just a question of where the
balance is right for sure so it's crazy
to me that like people will look at like
illegal immigrants and be like we need
to we need to ship 13 million people out
of here because a few people every year
get killed by
ms-13 or we need to get them all out of
here and then we look at like
3 000 people a day dying from the
coronavirus
and it's like well do we really need the
world they're they're very very
different
they're very different the issue of
illegal immigration has a lot to do with
the economy as well
just way more than just it has to do
with this the security of uh
of our elections the security of our
physical you know safety
and it has to do with the uh jobs market
so elections physical safety and jobs
market the coronavirus is
hardcore affecting all of those right
and all the millions you can't you can't
deport the coronavirus
and so the conservatives tend to say we
should protect the vulnerable
we should have social distancing wear
masks and
we can keep the economy running and
schools seem to be safe
and then the left senses say tends to
say lock it all down provide stimulus
and and support
so i i i hear what you're saying you
know early on because we go through this
already
like i guess the thing that makes me sad
is that like i grew up my so half my
family's cuban my mom
and dad were both air force they're ride
or die for trump
at like to the end of the earth um and
my mom is an incredibly
nationalistic very proud american loves
this country would would
if the air force called her back in
today she would you know strap up in her
little flight suit and go and fly to
wherever they wanted i know she would
um and it hurts when i grew up hearing
about all these amazing things that
america was capable of that america had
accomplished um and we did the silent
generation world war ii that we did a
lot of amazing stuff
and then when it comes to controlling a
coronavirus
individually we can't take
responsibilities we can't just wear a
mask and stay away from people
apparently that's really controversial
we sucked at getting testing out because
trump didn't take it seriously he didn't
push for anywhere near as much as he
showed up we weren't able to enact any
of the other measures that other
countries that was a complicated point
though but
we'll come back i don't believe it was
complicated i understand that we can say
that like well some tests were put out
they failed
i think that in the united states
regardless of what some people say i
think that this country possesses the
greatest technological innovation in the
world if we wanted to get tests out and
if the political
will was behind it we would have had
that out way earlier because south korea
had these same
first a reported case as us and they
have like i think they have like 240
deaths from the coronavirus why couldn't
that have been us
in south korea this entire little
peninsula like a like a metric
that's why it's easier for them that's
harder no no new york
one of those when new york city got so
crunchy tightly packed together
everybody's in all the international
travel and everything look how many
different states with different
jurisdictions with different governors
all protected by the 10th amendment
trump can only do so much
and when you have new york uh city
having their their health experts come
down and say everything's fine go
outside
you have people in california nancy plus
you're doing the same thing
there's an argument of who took things
more seriously than and who didn't but
ultimately what it comes down to is
trump doesn't have uh
vosh argued trump should use constitute
the constitutional war powers to just
assume control
and then force things so firstly that
would be insane
imagine if trump would be using like
executive powers
in times of national security to do
insane stuff like
tariffing china or sending troops down
to build the wall
i mean he's already done this these
weren't even national emergencies
but no i'm not in favor of that it's
well it's yeah because he shouldn't have
done it there but you could make an
argument that he might do it here maybe
he should
if there was ever an argument to
exercise these powers he would probably
be in protecting like
a 9 11's were the people dying every
single day in the united states i don't
know if like tariffing china is the same
level of national security
and that's why it's not a big deal what
do you mean well trump putting a tariff
on china people say for the most part
like okay we'll see how that plays out
well no
a lot of people were very upset because
he did this unilaterally any any
exercise executive branch powers to do
it under like threat of like war or
whatever like which is a little bit
insane
so i'm just saying i don't agree with
washi's argument uh but like if you're
going to argue in favor of trump abusing
the executive like he has so far it
seems strange to make the argument that
he shouldn't do it here has he abused
the executive
i think that saying that we need to go
that the the border wall to the south is
some like
horrible national emergency that he
needs to send people down to like build
part of his wall or whatever or saying
that we need to
have a national emergency tariff i think
that's very strange i think that's an
abuse of power
and then more importantly back to what
you said before trump can only do so
much trump
actually can do so much because he is so
unbelievably popular in the republican
party trump still has like a well like a
93 94
approval rating if trump went around
yeah if trump went around and told the
governors listen up guys
we're going to close down for a couple
months because it's your patriotic duty
blah blah blah you better
believe that any republican governor or
anybody that's in any plus trump
district is going to be in lockstep
behind them because they don't want to
lose reelections
in terms of securing the border that is
the power bestowed upon the president
if he's going to say the united states
government we need to protect our
borders we do if he's going to do
trade negotiations it's something order
policy and border legislation though
that's clearly in the realm of like
congressional authority this is stuff
that should be passed through congress
this went through a series of checks and
balances congress fought with trump they
refused to give the budget he wanted the
supreme court sided with trump
exactly he does have very broad powers
but like
spiritually speaking right i don't think
we would want biden or obama to come in
and say like oh well i'm going to open
all the borders because i think it's
good for a national security right
i personally i would say like this feels
like something that should probably go
through congress you know
i didn't like daca under obama not
because i didn't like the policy
but because it's like okay well we can't
get anything done through congress so
now we're going to like
kind of broaden our executive powers and
write immigration and we see how
horrible that is because anything that
can be done
via executive action can be undone via
executive action they can't
trump tried to undo it the supreme court
said no well i think um
so technically it's true but weren't
there parts of daca that i think were
rescinded i i don't know if that's still
being fought in an ongoing manner but i
know that they they basically shut them
down on several
instances yeah complicated things go
back and forth um but um
yeah like executive order is just a
really bad there are parts of our
government that people complain about so
the supreme court is one of them and the
executive is one of them and they say
that the power has expanded so much in
these areas
but i think the reason why it appears
just because congress has been so
unable to do anything that that's the
only place that we can get any
meaningful
action out of thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you